we were promised a better christmas than
last year but soaring infections left
people and plans in limbo december
descended into disarray but now some
clarity we don't
think
today that there is enough evidence to
justify any tougher measures before
christmas
and we continue to monitor omnichrome
very closely and if the situation
deteriorates we will be ready to take
action if needed
christmas is safe but what happens next
feels much less certain it's been very
difficult for all of us
and yeah so hopefully
things will get better for new year i
hope so relieved that
they're not further restrictions
concerned that this pandemic is ripping
through
hopeful that this pandemic isn't as
dangerous as previous versions and
nobody really seems to know i work for
music venues so we've got obviously a
lot of stuff in the new year um on new
year's eve parties and stuff so i
suppose if
restrictions get implemented on like the
28th or something that's obviously going
to be more of a headache for us from a
work perspective
the rapid rise of omicron makes it
impossible to rule out further measures
cases of coronavirus remain high above
90 000 cases a day the biggest concern
is around the rapid spread of omicron
this chart shows how much it's gone up
in just the last six days up by a third
to over sixty thousand cases and
hospitalizations
have increased slightly but remain well
below the numbers we were seeing during
the previous surges in infections
the rate of hospital admissions will be
critical in the coming days new
modelling data is due soon and this is
why many experts say delaying decisions
isn't unreasonable if the
hospitalization rate is higher than is
expected given you know the evidence
from from south africa and the early
data we have so far then that would mean
that the outcome you know is going to be
uh
you know towards the the more
pessimistic end of those of those models
um but it's also equally possible based
on the data we've had so far that we're
going to be much near the optimistic end
of the models
there is relief for families finally
able to get together but for many the
celebrations feel muted further measures
could be coming and we have no idea what
that might mean laura bundock sky news